50 shades star J me Jordan was spotted
signing autographs at the Toronto Film
Festival but before that he was with us
talking exclusively about his next
chapter and get ready ladies his
modeling past I've never done the runway
thank God
I don't a great walk there's earlier
modeling stuff that I was probably less
impressive I don't keep a book that way
so he doesn't have the models strut down
but he's definitely mastered the sultry
look these days the Fifty Shades star is
all about looking to the future up next
for the 36 year old well he's one of
Robin Hood's Merry Men hitting theaters
in November the dad of two girls also
just wrapped voicing apart in the 2020
sequel to trolls I would have done too
much work so far in my career that the
kids could watch and I was quite mindful
of us and they were going through a
particularly obsessive trolls period
when I sort of asked a few questions
about whether I could be involved in the
second and now the Northern Ireland
native is the face of Hugo Boss his
fragrance boss the scent we're getting
some serious Fifty Shades vibes from the
new add and wife of five years Amelia
well she told me she loves it
I'd never met anyone like her before
he's very passionate about fragrance
she's really into fragrance and now that
he's an expert in the field we asked
Jamie to name a fragrance after some of
his famous co-stars like Jamie Foxx the
suave I don't know he seems pretty very
cool person how about Rita Ora sassy and
of course Dakota Johnson oh the Dakotas
B loyalty that's nice I was far too nice
[Music]
[Applause]